all right Ben we have a new bachelor
Peter Webber I've never met him I hope
to at some point but I have no clue how
he is human well what do you think of
him is the choice he's a pilot he's from
California you had to have watched him
on Hanah season I definitely did yeah he
so he was kind of the guy that snuck up
on me because he looks super innocent
and I actually bet he is but then you
saw some pretty heavy like scenes with
him in Hanna during the scene you know I
think the two frontrunners were Mike and
Peter and Peter was the one chosen I
think he's gonna be loved I think people
are gonna really enjoy him but I do
think they'll be a little controversy
around why Mike wasn't chosen but I do
think Peters a great choice and I think
we should be happy that we have a guy
like him leading the franchise well do
you think that Mike should have been
chosen I think he would have been great
as well
I don't know as two men without knowing
them personally at all I can't say who
would've been a better lead but I think
they both made a really good run in it
we didn't see a lot of you know the one
thing that we didn't see is we didn't
see a lot of Mike in Paradise and I
think if we would have we would have
fallen in love with his love story a
little bit more but even I'm watching
paradise right now
and I don't seem to ever see Mike and so
for that I get why maybe Peter was
chosen because I think we maybe relate
with him a little bit more I know well a
lot of people will say like you said
controversy they'll say but when are we
getting the first black bachelor yeah
well that's a good question I don't have
any say in that and I think this will
bring up the conversation once again
it's not I mean it's been one that it's
been talked about since I was a bachelor
and way before I was a bachelor it's
when I'm getting asked all the time I
don't know I think when it's the right
guy it'll be the right guy I don't know
Mike again so I can't say it but we have
to silver Peter but I will say this I
think if Mike in Paradise if we really
fell in love with this story I think it
would be the perfect choice but instead
we just didn't seem long do you think
we're gonna get a sexy season with Peter
Webber we've come off the windmills it's
very fresh Peter Peters yeah you know
he's sneaky he has the smile he has a
charm he doesn't have the rough and
rugged look so he kind of you know looks
like this innocent boy I don't send your
open up his counsel is full of condoms
so yes I think it's going to be a very
intim
season I have a feelin of a feeling that
uh I mean I this might be crazy
[Music]
you